[音楽]
僕は偏差値5番上智大学
現在YouTubeやtiktokに動画
を上げているSNSインプレッサーです
いきなりあのこんな自己紹介をしてこう
なんだこいつ偏差値5万ってなんやねんと
思われた方もいると思うんですけどその僕
はあの状況に対してどうかしっていうあの
SNSのチャンネルで今
活動していまして名前はケントと言います
上智大学ドイツ語学科3年生で大分県出身
で大学進学とともに上京してその時には
もうあのカメラを握ってそこから動画投稿
開始しましたで内容はvlog形式を用い
て大学生の子日常を切り取ったような動画
を自分今発信していますでまずは
百聞は一見にしかずということで僕が実際
に投稿してSNSで100万回再生された
動画を皆さんにお見せできたらなという
ことでこちらをご覧ください
いかがでしたでしょうか
自分でもかなり面白いと思ってるんです
けど
僕の動画をよくSNSに投稿されるような
こうキラキラした動画ではなくて本当に
こう大学生のこう日常切り取った形を
韻を踏んで
面白おかしく動画にしてますではこういっ
た動画がこうありがたいことに多くの方に
指示していただいて動画投稿開始から2
年間2年でSNSは10万人を達成して今
はその運用経験をもとに
起業をして
企業さんのコンサルティングであったりと
か
講演会っていう風なことをさせていただい
ております2月には下北沢でラーメン屋
オープンさせまして僕は急になんかSNS
のインプレッサーとして
活動してたんですが急にこう
企業っていう言葉があの出てきたと思うん
ですけどこれもこう自分が自分の人生を
生きるっていうことをテーマに生きてきた
結果このような
成功ではないですけど成功を務めることが
できました
つまりこう周りにこう流されずに自分の
人生を生きる自分の好きなことをや
るっていう事だと思うんですけど本当に
それは自分
口で言うほどそれ本当に簡単なことでは
ないなっていうことを自分自身本当に実感
してかなりこう
辛い経験とかのような経験をしていきまし
たでなので今回は自分の人生を生き
るっていうことをテーマに自分がどのよう
な考えで
起業したりとかこう自分がインフル
エンサーとして学生起業家としてどのよう
な考え方を持っているのかっていうところ
を皆さんにお伝えできたらなっていうふう
に思っておりますこの公園の後に皆さんに
自分の人生について
考えていただいたりとか周りにこう流され
ないような考え方を持っていただけると
幸いです
今ではこうあの動画投稿だけではなくて
ラーメン屋とかもやってこうどんどんこう
華々しいと言ったらあれなんですけどこう
いう成果を残しているので
高校時代から
必死だったでしょみたいな大学入学当初
からすごい成果残してたでしょって思わ
れると思うんですけど実際そんなことも
全然なくてもう自分が中学生とか高校生の
頃本当にもう周りの人がこう選ぶような道
をずっとこう
経験してきて先生とか親がいい大学に行き
なさいとか公務員になりなさいとかあの大
企業に入ってあの安定した職を安定した
生活を送りなさいとかそのようなこと
ばっかを言われ続けて自分もそうだそうだ
と思ってずっとこう生活してきたんです
けど
でもそのままこう学校でずっともう勉強し
ていましたでこのような状況の時に自分の
意見を本当に持たずに本当に人が言われた
ことをそのままこう行動するっていう人生
をこのそういうふうな生活を行ってた時は
本当に自分のやりたかったこととかし
たかったことが本当に見えなくて自分でも
そういうふうなことを
やろうとも全然思っていませんでした
そんな考え方を大学でもやっぱり継続し
たくないなっていうふうに思ってで何か
新しいことをしようって思った時が大学
受験の時で自分が先ほどの大分県出身って
言ったんですけど自分の高校は
九州内の国公立大学に行くことが本当に
もう美徳というかそれがもう一番正しいと
いう風な考え方だったんですけどそこから
1個こう
逸脱して自分は東京に何か行きたいって
思いがあったので東京の私立大学に進学
することを決意しました
でこう上京するってことは一つの選択肢も
あったんですけどやっぱりそのただ上京
するだけじゃただの東京の大学生であって
それを
そのまま生活とか勉強していたらただの
大学生だなと思ったのでこの何か新しい
こと始めようと思った時に簡単にこう自分
で動画を撮ってそれをアップロードできる
YouTubeっていう媒体があったので
じゃあYouTuberになろうかって
いうことで本当に状況当初から
YouTubeを始めましたでも
YouTubeって言われて本当にもう
キラキラしていてこう
輝かしいような感じで見られてて自分も
その一員になろうかなと思ってモテモテ
インフルエンサーになれると思ってもう
あのYouTubeの活動してたんです
けど
全然もう何もない本当に他の大学生の動画
が
伸びるほど本当に
甘くない世界で1年間
継続したんですけどYouTubeの
チャンネル登録者数は2000人ぐらい
しか行かなくて先ほどの見せたようなもう
ちょっとあの長い動画なんですけどそちら
を動画投稿したんですけど全然
伸びずに2年間経っても5000人行か
ないぐらいで自分の中で試行錯誤したりと
かしてたんですけど全然伸びませんでした
でえっとそこからこうなんだろうなあの
本当にいつか述べるだろうなと思って
ずっとこうなんか自分の動画いつかバズれ
ばいいだろうなと思ってずっと動画投稿し
てたんですけど全然伸びずに今とりあえず
動画投稿するっていう形だけ取っていまし
たでこうそんな日々を送る中ドイツに半年
間留学する機会を得ましたで初めはこう
自分はドイツの企業に就職しようという風
に思っていたのでドイツの言語力向上
メインでドイツ留学をしたんですけど
ドイツに行けば
ドイツの
留学の様子をYouTubeに撮れると
思ってこれは伸びると思ってもう周りには
もうあのドイツ系の動画がなかったので
競合いないともう動画伸びるもうこれでも
ウハウインフルエンサーだと思って行った
んですよで
まあ行ったんですけど全然動画
伸びなくてでもう本当に自分のその時あの
ドイツの言語力もなかなか伸びなくて
ちょっとこううつ状態というかちょっと
こう気持ちがの沈んで状態の時に自分って
何なんだろうみたいなご自分こう自分が何
する時に幸せを感じるんだろうとか結構
そういうふうな方向にちょっと考え始め
ちゃってでまああのそれをまあよくよく
考えてみるとそれは自己分析に当たるん
ですけどでこう自分が日本にいる時は本当
に
忙しいこと言い訳に自己分析から離れて
もう忙しい生活にただただ自分をこう
慣れさせているっていう状況だったんです
けど
留学に来てこういい意味でこう自分と
向き合う機会ができて自分について深く
考えました
中学校高校時代を振り返ってみると本当に
こう友達にあの勉強していることが好きで
友達の成績自分のアドバイスで友達の成績
を上げたりとかすることが本当にした時に
本当に幸せとかの喜びを感じていましたで
も小学校の時にも自分サッカーが得意なん
ですけどどうやったらボールが
遠くに飛んでいくのかみたいなことをお
友達にレクチャーしたりとかした時に本当
にこうなんだろう人のために何かするとか
アドバイスすることが自分を好きなんじゃ
ないかなっていう風にその
自己分析からそれを
あのそれが見えてきましたこんな
経験から自分は人の成功を手助けすること
が好きなんじゃないかなとか
こう人のために何かをすることに
幸せっていうのを見出していたので
そこにこう自分の終点というか事故を
置こうかなという風に思っていましたでも
他に何かこう楽しかった思い出ないかなと
かいうふうに思ってた時に
中高の時は本当にこう
ギャグで人を笑わせることに本当に
熱中していまして
そこで本当に人前に立ってこう人を笑わせ
るって事は本当に好きだったのであこれも
一つ自分の好きなことだなっていう風に
思いましてでまぁこれからも人前に立って
人を笑わせたりとか
影響を与えたりすることが自分にとっても
一番あのベストというか一番自分の軸に
なるのかなっていう風に思うようになり
ました
でもこの自己分析によって自分の行動とか
自分の言動で誰かのためになったりとか
こう誰かを笑顔に笑顔にすることが自分の
仕事だなっていう風に思うようになって
それがこう自分のSNSではないのかって
いうのをドイツで再認識することができ
ました
ここで自分の動画自分の動画自分の言動で
人にこうプラスの影響を与えるということ
がもう一番の自分の
軸となってそれが今後のSNSの
活動の
原動力になっていきます
でそこから本当にもう軸が定まると本当に
行動側の明確化してきてSNSより一層
こう自分がこう注力しするようになって
もう時間も何十時間何百時間って費やして
こう自分の動画キャラクターとしてこう
視聴者から求められているのは
大学で生活している自分っていうことが再
確認することができましたでこう自分に
とって好きなこととか
幸せなことしているとおのずとやっぱ自分
にこう自信が出てきて戦略も変わって今は
YouTubeその時はYouTube
しかしなかったんですけど流行ってた
tiktokにも参入してでも先ほど見せ
たようなあの
縦型の動画がやっぱり自分には
合っていてそこから一気に半年間で
フォロワー10万人を達成してそのおかげ
で今現在ここに今建てています
でまあこの経験から皆さんにお伝えしたい
ことはこれやりたいことを見つけるために
はでそしてこう周りに流されず自分の人生
を生きるためには自分自身がどんな人間か
知っているかどうかが一番重要だなって
いうふうに思っていますこれを知るために
は先ほど言ったように自己分析が本当に
必要で自己分析を通してこれ知ってる時
自分好きなんだなとかこれしてる時逆に
自分嫌いだなあとかそういうことがわかり
ますで皆さん本当にいろんな経験をされ
てると思うんですけどそこをやっぱこう
自分の中の
潜在的なこう
経験とか記憶とかをもう本当に小さい頃
から掘り起こしていくことが大切だと思っ
ていますこれをすることによって自分が
こうやりたいことが見えてきて
そこの自己分析の結果を踏まえて
失敗してもいいから自分がこうやりたい
こと貫くとか自分の人生を生き
るっていうことが本当に大事だなっていう
ふうに思ってますで最近あの新しく開店し
た
ラーメン屋さんも自分のもとに自分の軸を
元に
挑戦して本当に今回こう時間の都合上
詳しくお伝えできないんですけどこれも
こう自分の軸の中で視聴者にこう直接いい
影響をラーメン屋で与えたいっていう
ところから回転させました
話をまとめると自己分析をして自分自身を
もっと知ってほしいですそこからこう軸を
見つけて自分がこう納得のいく一番こう
ベストな
考えというか自己を見つけてほしいです
こう自分はよくこう就活をする時期なので
友達とよく大手企業に行くのかとか
ベンチャー企業に行くのかとか
旅をするのかとか
寺に行くとかなんかそんないろんな話を
するんですけどここで一番鍵なのが自己
分析をして自分がこう一番
納得のいける選択をしていれば別にどこに
行こうがあのお寺に行こう側の
いろんなところに行っていいっていう風に
思ってましてこうけどその中でもやっぱり
給料が安定しているからとか今後安泰だ
から大手に行きたいっていう友達が多く
いるんですけどそれ友達に対して僕はもう
めちゃくちゃ質問攻めしてなんでなんで
なんで聞くんですけどなんかもちろん友達
のことを思ってたんですけどそういう考え
方は
友達にとってこうベストな人生を歩めると
思ってないのでそういう風な感じでこう
いやいや質問をよくしてます
でこう自分がこう今後身につけたいスキル
とかがあるのであれあの
身につけたいからそのそこの企業に入りた
いっていうのであれば本当にも自分も
抱きしめて本当にいつも過ごしてます
で本当に大切なのは自分が何を感じるのか
こう確固たる自分だけの
軸を持ってほしいです決めるのは本当に
自分自身だと思っていますし自分の人生
自分の実行強く持って生きてほしいです
以上で終わります